Roxie's with us in Florida hey Roxie how
are you hey Dave how are you I'm so
happy to talk to you you too how can I
help
okay so about 13 months ago my boyfriend
and I at the time he's my fiancee now
found out we were pregnant and flash
forward to now we have a beautiful five
month-old girl and we're in a very
interesting position because we have no
consumer debt none zero and my fiancee
decided that he just needed to get his
income up and he went from making
literally nothing to bring in about
seventy thousand a year now he were in a
position of he's an over-the-road truck
driver so he's like baby also the bank
account you write the checks and I don't
want to let him down and I don't know I
having a baby has made me realized I
don't really understand money and in
order to be better with money I feel
like you need to understand it and I I
don't I'm terrified of debt and having
found you I realized that's the light
that got the white gut instinct so I
just wanted to know he's he's hell-bent
on buying a house but I kind of feel
like maybe that's a little putting the
cart before the horse maybe we should
continue to rent and you know yeah
that's kind of where I'm at so when is
the wedding date next year sometime we
already set a date I don't know he's got
a ring on my finger recently he just we
hadn't really talked about it because
he's driving like he drives you know
continually come so maybe you know would
you say if I say this is holding your
wealth-building back I'd say you're
probably right yeah because it's hard to
build wealth with your roommate
very true thank you
you don't buy a house with your roommate
and so if you know the you know you call
me and so I'm gonna tell you the
shortest path to wealth is for couples
that intend to live together is to be
married okay it's not a moral statement
it is a moral statement because I'm a
Christian and I believe that but aside
from that that's not why I'm bringing it
up how actually truth is it's probably
part of why I'm bringing it up but the
main the reason I'm gonna bring to you
is is that all the data points that we
have of people who win with money do it
in conjunction highly unified with their
spouse they don't do it in spite of
their spouse they don't do it in spite
of their boyfriend they don't buy houses
and cars and stuff with people that
they're not married to we just don't
find those people succeeding financially
in any of our research and in 30 years
of doing this I haven't seen it and so
that's why I'm bringing it up so you
don't hear you don't hear me being a
jerk in my voice right no no all right
good so this is just me telling you I
love you here's how I want you to win
okay so if I woke up in your shoes I'd
get married when he comes home okay
this weekend and then we would start
talking about how we're gonna handle
money as a married couple and I can help
you a lot better with that than I can
with your roommate now so then what
we're gonna do is you don't need to be
worried about letting him down because
you're gonna lay out the budget and the
two of you are both going to agree on
where the money's gonna go and you're
gonna write the checks on what you've
agreed to do okay so you're not gonna be
I'll just make mine throw it in the
account and I'll sure hope you get your
crap together back home baby
that doesn't work okay that's not fair
to you and ultimately it's not fair to
him cuz he's out there wondering if you
have a clue you're back home going crap
I sure
hope I have a clue right and that's just
too that's too much there's too much
guilt trip and going on back and forth
here so all I don't expect him to do a
lot but you I'm gonna put you into
Financial Peace University as my wedding
gift to you
okay and I want you to go to the class
and the thing about the class is it has
a one-year membership and all the videos
and the lessons are online and he can
watch them while he's on the road and
you're gonna do your budget on every
dollar and every dollar plus and he can
look at it on his phone he'll know
exactly what you're doing and the two of
you together are going to approve your
budget each month even if he's on the
road he can do it takes 30 minutes okay
well he's sitting in the hotel room you
put the baby to bed you've got the
budget built okay baby bring it up let's
jump on the phone let's look at the
budget okay all right you good with all
this good then you go do what both of
you agreed to then if there is a mistake
or a problem the two of you did it
together right if there's success the
two of you did it together and I cannot
recommend that to a couple that is not
married I can only recommend it to a
couple that's married because it
presents relationship problems and all
kinds of legal problems when you've
combined money with people you're not
married to right I'm buying a house with
people you're not legally married to is
really scary stuff so I agree I think
you guys are very close to being able to
buy a house you're debt-free let's build
your emergency fund those then let's
start working on a down payment and
we'll teach you all of that in Financial
Peace University probably by spring or
this time next year you're gonna be in
the market for a house and I think
that's gonna be fine the good news about
your man is heating afraid of hard work
he took off and got on the road and made
some money for his his fiancee and his
baby he's a good guy he's got a good
heart he's got a good work ethic you
probably found a keeper
so go ahead and lock him down when he
comes in this weekend close the deal all
right hang on Kelly's gonna pick up I'll
get you signed up for Financial Peace
University oh and all you people that
don't like Dave Ramsey being judgmental
in all that Stephanie for him she's not
judgmental Dave Ramsey loves you I just
want you to win
and you can just put over whatever you
want you can write a blog about me while
you live in your mother's basement and
you can have your liberal fantasies or
whatever it is you're going to do that's
fine have at it I'm gonna keep doing
this show don't call this show if you
don't want my opinion because it is my
job to help you as best I can knowing
what I've learned in the last 30 years
of doing this what can i guide you to do
to help you the most even if you don't
like it even if the ideas are foreign to
you even if it feels funky to you
doesn't matter to me how it feels what I
want to do is I want to help you win
that's my goal and so she's probably
about the age of one of my daughters and
so if one of my daughters good friends
that has grown up in our neighborhood
came and sat down at the kitchen table
with Sharon and I it's exactly what I
would have told her to so if you don't
like that kind of stuff there's a real
easy fix for you change the channel this
is the Dave Ramsey show you want to tell
get you a show this is the Dave Ramsey
show